[Music]
well definitely I mean it's all he's
been part of what I've known what I've
done so I guess so you usually attach to
what you know where you come from I was
born in south Georgia sub-antarctic
island but my family's been sailing here
for over 40 years now I suppose home was
sort of more around this area for me my
mother had a background in biology and
although we were just cruising she had
an interest and started making notes she
made a lot of the first records of bird
colonies in all these areas
so why should people who don't live here
or don't know and time if you care about
this place
the Antarctic wake closely linked to
everything else in the planet the
landscape is shriveling it's drying up
you can see a lot of the ice recede and
the snow cover receding
Antarctic Treaty protects all things on
land and prohibits extraction of
resources and mainly mineral resources
they were thinking about however it
doesn't cover the sea so commercial
fishing is perfectly allowed all the
waters around Antarctica so we have a
situation where you're not supposed to
do anything to impact the world life
here on land but it's okay to go fishing
for what they literally just just offer
off the beach almost well I think it's
slight oversight of the Antarctic Treaty
of you ask me generally people won't be
able to change their habits unless
there's a direct effect on mera
day-to-day life
experience in places he way
to be for granted then and now you
realize that actually not ever gonna be
possible again change is inevitable but
it's rather traumatic
[Music]
[Music]